let's randomly choose our makeup so we
got blue as the skin tone starting off
make sure you prime really good protect
your skin let's add our oilbased face
paints we're going in with this blue
shade and the creativity paint stick is
eating it up all right we wanted blue
skin that's what we gave this looks
crazy I said I look nuts let's go in for
our concealer color so it was white I
said okay and it just made light blue
which I was cool with anyways these were
easy to blend but I went in with a puff
to BL blend instead of like a sponge
because I didn't want the product to get
soaked up I just wanted to press it into
place it's giving handsome squid work I
bed another blue pencil but I said we
going to do purple all right I went in
with my eyeshadow now to Contour my face
and then we pulled pink for the Brows I
said okay wait a minute though we're
going orange on the lid because now I
got a look in mind like you don't get to
choose anymore I'm going to finish it
off all right we finished her off with a
cute lip lashes and of course we got to
put the blue in the lace you see the
outcome I don't know what this is giving
but it's giving that's all I know all
right the skin is eating some people
were actually mad I didn't let the
filter make me look crazy so let's just
go what it says um a ribbon okay this is
already starting off nut I guess we
starting with blocking the brow I'm so
interested to see how this comes
together y'all like I'm scared try to
mix my eyes Shadow to get that color
outline it now fix it later I mean we
getting somewhere I got to add some
Shadows or something to this not going
to lie I spend way too much time on
these okay ey Shadow keep up with the
them like you did last time that's so
ugly I'm a very matchy matchy person but
it might look cute at the end going to
do my face makeup and then come back for
the under eye I guess it is giving
Christmas since the theme I guess is
just Christmas give me
Christmas it's not even Christmas wow
wow boring very antic the fact that last
time it worked so well with me and this
time it just said screw it music
notes okay see y'all going to really
wish I had been able to change that
filter when I start adding this gray on
my nose gray like why gray for Christmas
cars like Thanksgiving F la la la la lip
I simply need you to just draw all this
together no it was like a similar color
to my ribbons let's see how it came out
I legitimately don't even know what I'm
looking at right now throw the whole
look away I need my husband's reaction
cuz this looks crazy wow that's
that's different I like that I like that
you did something different yeah
different you got the notes on there I
love that okay oh yeah yeah what the you
made your eyebrows in the
[Music]
bow
on